we begin in Montreal where countries at
the U.N biodiversity Summit have adopted
a historic deal to protect nature the
agreement is the most significant effort
yet to protect vital ecosystems
safeguarding 30 percent of the world's
land and seas the deal also promotes
agricultural reforms and provides
critical financing to save biodiversity
in the developing world
Beatrice christophero from our
environment desk is covering the story
for us Beatrice 190 countries have
struck a deal to protect biodiversity
this deal is being hailed as historic
what makes it so significant many
environmentalists are saying that this
deal is our last chance to you know
reverse the threat on our biodiversity
which basically refers to all living
things on earth so if we look at the
situation right now where thousands of
species are under threat of Extinction
or insect numbers are plummeting our
oceans are acidifying the situation is
very dire and our ecosystems are under
enormous pressure so this deal could
change the way we Farm the way we do
business and the way we protect our
animals and plants the steel was
hammered out in a series of really tough
negotiations uh you mentioned 190
countries getting them to agree on
something is is really significant what
what
were the points of contention the
biggest content point of contention by
far was financing and that's something
we already saw at the climate talks uh
which were also U.N talks in in Egypt in
November because it really boils down to
this that poor nations want richer
Nations to give them more financial aid
to help them in their conservation
efforts especially because these
developing nations are the ones that
really are home to some of the most
outstanding biodiversity for example if
you think of the Amazon in South America
so these negotiations got so heated at
one point that delegates from poor
Nations walked out of the negotiations
okay so how much of a game changer do
you think this deal will really be do
you think that it can actually help stop
the Relentless degradation of plant and
animal life on the planet
if this deal becomes a game changer
really depends on the way we implement
it the way that governments honor the
promises that and the commitments that
they made in these negotiations because
as we've seen in other historic deals
before for example the the Paris
agreement in 2015 which focused on
climate talks these commitments are not
always honored I mean really big
promises were made in terms of global
warming in in periods at that point and
the way things are going right now we're
not honoring them so with this deal we
also got to see okay we made the
promises but are we going to walk the
walk
you mentioned the the climate uh
negotiations that have been going on
we've said in seeing those those
agreements broken how does this deal on
biodiversity plug into the whole notion
of climate change because they are of
course closely related exactly experts
are saying that they're completely
interlinked and that to fight climate
change we also got to protect our
biodiversity especially ecosystems such
as forests so to come back to my example
of the Amazon the this like massive
rainforest is absolutely crucial to
absorb carbon from the atmosphere
because this keeps the atmosphere from
heating up so the more we DeForest the
more we threaten our climate also and
similarly uh for us to protect our our
the more we pollute and the more we emit
that also is a massive threat on our
biodiversity
Pinterest thank you very much for your
insights that was Beatrice Christopher
from our environment desk thank you